one of the most intriguing aspects of
Byrd box is that we never actually see
the creatures that are terrorizing the
world but if you watch very carefully we
are given some crucial little clues
about them and who they've killed
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video i'm revealing seven
monstrous details you may have missed
when watching Netflix's viral sensation
bird box plus i'll be revealing some
brand-new behind-the-scenes photos of a
monster that was designed for the movie
but never used spoilers ahead so take
care if you haven't seen the film yet
the first details of the monsters emerge
after everyone who's holed up inside
Douglass's house tried to figure out
what's going on but it's Charlie who
probably has the best insight into what
humanity is now up against he explains
that what's happening is the end game
and he lists the names of various
mythological demons and malevolent
religious entities that he's been
studying for a book he's writing the a
kumano that Charlie mentions is often
depicted as a horned entity and one of
Gary's sketches resembles a Zoroastrian
demon a kumano signifies evil mind evil
purpose evil thinking or evil intention
which fits in nicely with how the
monsters in Bird box take over the minds
of people who see them depictions of a
kumano sometimes show him manipulating
people like they're puppets on a string
and he's a particularly cruel and
intelligent demon who ultimately seeks
death for the humans he controls in a
post-apocalyptic movie like bird box
it's pretty much expected that many of
the characters we meet will end up
getting killed off with a few exceptions
but some of the deaths in berg box are
much harder to spot than others for
example you probably didn't take in what
happened to the couple who ran out of
Douglass's house to try and rescue their
children broadside your gun or outfit
won't make it to your children
well when Tom and Koh drive out to the
supermarket their car passes over a
number of dead bodies in the street
there's a stomach-churning moment when
we see the car about to roll over a
corpse followed by the sickening sound
of bones crunching and if you look at
the close-up of that body before the car
hits you'll see it's actually the guy
who left the house several days earlier
and behind him is his wife the body that
gets run over has the same
blue jacket light top and beige trousers
the guy had on in Douglass's house and
the body of the woman behind him as the
same cream and pale colored clothing his
wife was wearing including the little
bit of lace at the base of her top there
are some interesting details in
Mallory's paintings at the beginning of
the movie that hint at what's to come
one of the painting seems to foreshadow
the monstrous apocalypse unfolding on
the TV screen behind Mallory you need to
look very closely but there's a deer
with what may be a wolf behind it but
even more strikingly there's some kind
of monster to its side it looks like a
huge serpent has opened its jaws about
to attack the deer and on top of that
the head of the snake seems to be
emerging from an even larger whale like
mouth that's about to snap up both the
animals who seemed oblivious to their
fate and if you look even closer you can
see what appears to be the head of a
large beaked bird in the trees behind
the huge Beast
obviously the paintings open to
interpretation but it makes me think of
the final scenes in the movie where
Mallory is running through the forest
fleeing this enormous malevolent force
chasing her through the trees the wind
seems like it could devour Mallory and
the children in this shot just like the
monster in this painting is about to
swallow up the animals another sinister
being that shows up in Garry's drawings
is Cthulhu a Lovecraftian cosmic entity
that lives beneath the earth his
appearance in bird box is especially
relevant because in the mythos of
Cthulhu simply gazing upon him will
drive an ordinary human insane it's said
that he and other alien like beings
exist at a level we humans simply cannot
comprehend which is why even looking at
him would drive us to madness HP
Lovecraft description of Cthulhu
mentioned an octopus like head whose
face was a mass of feelers a scaly
rubbery looking body and the picture in
Garry's drawings definitely fits that
interestingly and fittingly for our
movie Cthulhu has cult followers similar
to the worshippers of the creatures in
bird box this group has been able to
look upon the monsters and rather than
killing themselves they feel enlightened
the man who attacks Mallory on the boat
tells her that everyone must look and
that it shall cleanse the world Geary
and fish fingers the possessed guy at
the supermarket say how beautiful the
creature is and they both fanatically
use whatever tricks they can to gain
access to survivors to convert them to
their core
the post-apocalyptic scenario bird box
also ties in with the idea that many
Cthulhu cult has some believers have
that when Cthulhu and his fellow gods
rise again the human race will be
destroyed
so Cthulhu seems to be a big inspiration
for Byrd box even if there's an array of
other drawings and sketches that Gary
lays out on the coffee table confirming
that the monsters in the movie likely
look different to different people by
the way I wonder if the reason Gary has
drawn so many different versions of the
monsters is because he has some kind of
disassociative identity disorder
aka multiple personality disorder or
alternatively he may have collected them
together from other people at the mental
institution a [ __ ] Douglass's house
that Mallory gets interested in is by
Giovanni / an AZ an Italian artist who
was known for his atmospheric actions of
imaginary prisons which have been a
major influence on films such as
metropolis Blade Runner and the third
man writers like Edgar Allen Poe and
Franz Kafka and artists including MC
Escher similar to Pyrenees drawings the
monsters in Bird box create an imaginary
prison in the mind of their victims
remember what Charlie said that is the
entity that takes on a form of your
worst fears or your deepest sadness or
your greatest loss so the monsters cut
individuals off from others locking them
away in their own minds in other words
they create a prison of fear sadness and
loss inside people's heads which nobody
else could see or understand the true
horror of that eventually leads them to
either suicide or possession and control
by the creatures in the case of
characters like Gary or fish fingers
mallory herself suffers from an
emotional disconnect with the rest of
the world at the beginning of the movie
but she very gradually connects with
other people like Tom and eventually by
the end she breaks out of her own
figurative prison connecting with the
children she's raised and the community
she's joined a curious reference to
another source of weird and wonderful
creatures comes via a book that Mallory
grabs to read while Greg is trying to
observe the creatures via the security
camera footage the book she's holding
while talking to Charlie is called
cabinet of natural curiosities by the
18th century Dutch natural historian
Alberta Seaver and appropriately enough
it's full of drawings of real-life and
mythical beasts range
creatures of the deep to an array of
snakes and a creepy seven-headed Hydra
monster that's especially difficult to
defeat as cutting a head off the Beast
causes another two to grow in its place
in my alternate ending and deleted
scenes video I spoke about how the
creatures were originally going to
appear in a scene in bird box and since
making that video the special-effects
makeup company KNB EFX have released
photos of what the creature would have
looked like during Mallory's deleted
nightmare scene these are some pictures
shared on Instagram by KNB EFX co-owner
Howard burger on the left is the design
for the prosthetic piece for the monster
that was then placed on actor Dirk
Rogers and makeup applied on top the
final results is in the bottom right
corner this deleted scene was originally
in the movie because according to
screenwriter Eric Heisler one of the
producers was insisting that a creature
had to be shown at some point director
Susana beer also explained this although
a lot of time and expense went into
filming the creature scene when they
reviewed it it didn't feel it was scary
enough and with these new pictures we
can see why Sandra Bullock described the
look of the creature a snake-like and
resembling a long fat baby I don't know
if there were ever any plans to add any
additional CGI effects on top of the
creature in post-production to make it
more menacing but I can see why this
scene was cut in the end as a real
horror of the monsters in bird boxes
that they tap into each individual's
deepest fear so by giving them a
definitive form the scariness would be
lost for many viewers and if you want to
find out more about other deleted scenes
and the horrific alternate ending to
bird box that didn't make it into the
movie you can tap in the top right for
my video on that or check the links in
the video description so did you spot
any other cool details in bird box and
what do the monsters represent for you
let me know in the comments below every
week I have new movie breakdowns and
coming soon I'll be taking a look at the
film glass if you enjoyed this be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell to stay up to date with my new
videos tap left to watch my bird box
alternate ending explained video or tap
write for another video you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers